mélanie bonsoir et félicitations je
rappelle que vous avez remporté donc la
médaille d'or au sol la médaille
d'argent par équipes et la médaille de
bronze à la poutre
qu'est-ce que vous visez désormais et
maintenant je me prépare déjà pour un
championnat du monde après on a encore
un stage aux états unis donc j'ai le
temps vraiment de concentrer les
préparer et les internationaux de france
c'est une très belle quand les
championnats du monde fin octobre début
novembre à noah et qu'est ce qui vous
motive pour sa remporté une médaille
alors une semaine à peine de vacances
reprise de l'entraînement ce matin celui
bientôt dans vous l'avez dit davantage
aux états unis c'est une discipline qui
demande beaucoup de sacrifices comment
est ce qu'on le vit à votre âge et j'ai
commencé très tôt à 18 ans aujourd'hui
mais j'ai commencé très tôt je suis
parti à l'âge de 12 ans en france
c'était très dur au début parce que
j'étais loin de ma famille mais après la
gym ça prend tellement de temps dans ma
vie que je vais je me lève je vais à la
gym j'ai pas besoin de réfléchir et on
est parti à l'âge de 12 ans on a
retrouvé justement des images de 2012
des images de vous c'était lors d'un
camping au prêcheur voir ces images avec
d'autres il n'a c'était quelques mois
donc avant justement khunkitti la
martinique pour saint-etienne ça me
rappelle des souvenirs y est vous était
déjà très très très motivés à cette
époque là
et même si c'était un peu difficile de
savoir veuillez partir pour quitter vos
parents je me suis enfin je profitais
vraiment des derniers moments qu'il me
restait afin de rester en martinique
alors j'étais pas trop un souci alors
pour les gens de ma génération c'est
peut-être très loin pour vous la
référence en gymnastique ces thèmes à
dire comme adachi tous les jeunes
gymnastes voulais lui ressembler quelle
a été celle qui vous aspirez vous si
mauvaise qu'on écrive il est d'ailleurs
payé le dernière elle vous inspirez
d'accord et donc vous allez retrouver
prochainement donc aux etats unis c'est
quoi c'est une rencontre à quelqu'un que
retrouver comme une icône ni connu
nastic la meilleure mondiale fins et
c'est la simone bail c'est la meilleure
vous devenez à votre tour
une sorte de modèle pour les jeunes
martiniquais mais aussi les jeunes
français d'autant que vous êtes si je ne
me trompe pas la première française à
devenir championne d'europe au sol
depuis isabelle severino en 2005 c'est
une lourde responsabilité maintenant
oui et non ça me donne envie de faire
encore mieux de rentrer encore plus dans
l'histoire de la gym française et après
oui c'est sûr que si je dois garder mon
statut est toujours présente au sol même
si on pourrait avoir le plaisir de
regarder les médailles que vous devez
rapporté un hors jeu rappelle une
médaille d'or gymnastique au sol une
médaille d'argent par équipe avec
l'équipe de france et puis la médaille
de bronze à la poutre c'est formidable
de pouvoir faire tout ça donc dans une
seule compétition
oui médaille de bronze c'est marine
voyez qu'il l'a fait et je suis très
fière d'elle aussi les médailles bas ça
c'est au sol et je finis par celle là
parce que c'est la meilleure c'est vice
championne d'europe par équipes
je pense que c'est celle que j'aime le
plus parce que c'est ce qu'on attendait
vraiment avec l'équipe
un dernier mode de là où j'étais j'ai vu
le reportage sur votre retour triomphal
à la martinique et votre grand mère qui
n'arrête pas de dire que vous aimez
beaucoup si je ne me trompe pas les
pauvres ian way est ce que vous avez eu
le temps d'en manger bien manger je vais
aller au marché à frauder france
oui merci beaucoup mais dany de jésus
santos on vous souhaite bon courage pour
ce stage aux états unis déjà pour
l'entraînement et le stage aux états
unis et surtout pour le championnat du
monde
elle doit en octobre prochain